in this segment we discussed the so
called random incidence paradox for the
Poisson process it's a paradox because
it involves a somewhat counterintuitive
phenomenon however we will understand
exactly what's going on and in the end
it will cease to be a paradox and we
will have an intuitive understanding of
what exactly is happening so consider a
Poisson process that has been running
forever or a think of it as a Poisson
process that started a very long time
back in the past to make things concrete
suppose that the arrival rate is four
arrivals per hour so that the expected
inter arrival time is 1/4 in hours or
that would be the same as 15 minutes for
example suppose that the bus company in
your town claims that buses arrive to
your stop according to a Poisson process
with this particular rate but you don't
really believe that your bus company is
telling the truth and you decide to
investigate so what you do is the
following you show up at some time at
your bus stop and wait until the next
arrival comes and also ask someone who
lives near the bus stop what time was
the last arrival and they tell you the
last arrival happened at that time
instant and you measure this amount of
time which is the inter arrival time
record what it is repeat this experiment
on many days and calculate an average
what you're likely to see turns out to
be something around 30 minutes at this
point you could go to the bus company
and challenge them you claim on arrival
rate of four arrivals per hour which
would translate into inter arrivals of
15 minutes but every day I go and check
the inter arrival
time and I find that there are close to
30 minutes what's the explanation what's
going on is it that the belief or the
claim of the bus company is incorrect
or is there something more complicated
so let us try to understand what's going
on by being very precise and careful you
show up at the bus station at some time
let's call that time T star you ask
someone who has been at the station when
was the last time and they tell you and
it is some number you you wait until the
next bus and the next bus arrives at
some future time capital v you are
interested in the inter-arrival time
that you are observing which is the
difference between those two random
variables v minus u now this difference
let us split it into two pieces there is
one piece from T star until V which is V
minus T star and there is another piece
which is the first interval and this is
T star minus u now T star the time at
which you arrive is just a constant
suppose that you arrive at the bus
station at exactly 12:00 noon there's
nothing random about it however V and u
are random variables
what kind of random variable is this you
show up at 12 noon and you wait until
the first arrival because the Poisson
process starts fresh at any given time
so after 12 noon it starts fresh this is
the time until the first arrival in a
Poisson process with rate lambda so this
is a random variable which is
exponential with parameter lambda now
let us understand what this random
variable is one way of thinking about it
is to think of the Poisson process
running backwards in time so you live
time back
you show up at 12 noon and then time
runs backwards and you wait until you
see a first arrival coming in this
backwards universe so we're dealing here
with the time until an arrival in a
Poisson process that trans backwards in
time what kind of process is a backwards
Poisson process if you take a Poisson
process in Reverse time the independence
assumption is not affected disjoint time
intervals are independent even if you
reverse time disjoint time intervals
still remain independent any given time
interval of small length Delta will have
certain probabilities of an arrival or
of two arrivals and this will be the
same whether time goes forward or time
goes backward so the conclusion from
this discussion is that the backwards
running Poisson process is also Poisson
process and so this time until the first
arrival in the backwards process is just
like the time until the first arrival in
a Poisson process so this also is an
exponential random variable with
parameter lambda even more than that
these two random variables are
independent of each other why are they
independent the length of this time
interval has to do with the history of
the Poisson process after time T star
the length of this time interval has to
do with this history of the Poisson
process before time T star but in the
Poisson process because of the
independence property the past and the
future are independent and therefore
this random variable is independent from
that random variable in any case the
expected value of the inter-arrival
interval that you see the expected value
of this random variable is going to be
the expected value of one exponential
which is one over lambda plus the
expected value of another x
nancial which is one over lambda and we
get a result of two over lambda and
that's why when you actually carried out
the experiment you saw inter-arrival
intervals that had a length of 30
minutes as opposed to the 15 minutes
that you were expecting in the first
place now how can this be since the
inter arrival times in a Poisson process
have expected value 1 over lambda how
can it be that the expected length of
the inter arrival times that you see
have an expected value of 2 over lambda
well the resolution of this paradox has
to do by what exactly we mean when we
use the words an inter arrival time
there's one interpretation which is the
first inter arrival time the second one
the hundredth inter arrival time each
one of these actually has an expected
value of 1 over lambda but this is a
different kind of inter arrival time
it's not the first or the second or some
specific safe inter arrival time it's
the inter arrival time that you selected
to watch when you show up at a certain
time like 12:00 noon you're more likely
to fall inside a large inter-arrival
interval rather than a smaller
inter-arrival interval so just the fact
that you're showing up at a certain time
that uncoordinated with the rest of the
process makes you more likely to be
biased towards longer rather than
shorter intervals and this bias is what
causes this factor of 2 so it's an issue
really about how you sample or how you
choose the inter arrival time that
you're going to watch and this
particular sampling method has a bias
towards longer intervals as we will see
this is not something that's specific to
the Poisson process
in general in many occasions there are
different ways of sampling which give
you different answers and we will go
through a number of examples that will
give you some intuition about the source
of the discrepancy between these two
answers